avec florian philippot président des
patriotes et jean paul stahl professeur
émérite de maladies infectieuses au chu
de grenoble
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce soir sur rtl france le nouveau
virus détectés au royaume uni il est
plus contagieux mais pas plus dangereux
est ce qu'on en est certain jean paul
stahl pas du tout pour l'instant on a
des communiqués de presse
alors c'est possible c'est tout à fait
possible
néanmoins je sais pas très clair quoi
qu'il en soit ça change pas grand chose
je veux dire le virus qui se transmet
d'un porteur un récepteur donc il faut
briser cette chaîne de contamination
porter vers le récepteur que le virus
soit plus ou moins transmissibles à
partir du moment où on a établi les
barrières les barrières sont là et ça a
changé grand chose
donc pour l'instant à mon avis et avec
les informations que j'ai je ne suis pas
virologues donc les informations que
j'ai c'est vraiment de des nouvelles au
conditionnel on va dire alors justement
c'est une annonce qui n'étonne
semble-t-il pas beaucoup de
scientifiques s'y attendait mais qui
prend en tout cas un forian physiquement
au dépourvu l'opinion publique déjà très
inquiète est ce qu on aurait pu celle ci
s'y préparer à cette annonce
écoutez moi j'ai pas des informations
scientifiques plus précise que ce qu'on
a lu effectivement dans les communiqués
de presse je pense qu'il faut par
précaution fermer la frontière ça ça me
paraît évident jeu de réclamer ce matin
après des mutations du virus j'ai évolué
les articles scientifiques ce soir elle
a déjà vu plus de 20000 sur ce corps là
virus donc c'est pas non plus un
phénomène rarissime
voilà je pense qu'il faut surtout garder
la tête froide et ne pas ne pas prendre
prétexte encore une fois de ce vilain
mutante pour aggraver la vague
d'hystérie et de pertes de nerfs dont
nous souffrons déjà beaucoup trop depuis
le début de cette crise ce qui fait que
nous ne gérons pas normalement
sereinement et efficacement ça c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
cette crise sanitaire mais nous faisons
un peu n'importe quoi parce que parce
qu'il a peur et que l'on vous en parle
sur le stress d'anxiété et la peur je
crains que ce mutant cette affaire du
mutant de face que renforcer ce climat
d'hystérie
surtout qu'on s'apprête justement à
débuter un si tout va bien si on a le
feu vert au niveau repère les campagnes
de vaccination fin décembre reste à
savoir si justement c'est une question
importante qui se pose ce soir si le
vaccin riser biotech est réellement
efficace contre la nouvelle souche
oui selon berlin et la france jean paul
stahl que faut-il en penser au mot 100 %
il ya absolument aucune raison pour
l'instant est que le vaccin ne soit pas
efficace
le vaccin estime uwe l'immunité je
dirais générique vis-à-vis du vis-à-vis
du ru virus pas forcément vis-à-vis d'un
but en spécifique ou d'une souche
spécifique il est multi souche si on
peut appeler ça comme ça
le coronavirus et pas du tout mais alors
pas du tout le wagon l'afrique c'est pas
du tout le même type de virus était
absolument pas l'aider des mutations qui
surviennent ni au même endroit ni avec
la même fréquence donc non pro qui a
vraiment scientifiquement aucune
incertitude sur l'efficacité du vaccin
pour l'instant en tout cas la faïence et
dépôts votre réaction
moi je constate qu'on sait rien sur ce
but en mais on sait déjà dans
l'habilleur que le vaccin reste efficace
bon et vous écoutez ça c'est quand même
assez assez surprenant on ne sait rien
sait rien encore nous a dit on sait rien
sur la rapidité de propagation
apparemment c'est juste que
effectivement ça se propage plus vite on
sait rien sur parce qu'il est plus grave
moins grave c'est pas par contre on sait
tout de suite que ce fameux vaccin est
déjà où cette thérapie génique
d'ailleurs et déjà efficace
bon moi façon je veux pas qu'on s'en
faire dans ce couple restrictions
confinement vaccin je pense qu'on
devrait remettre au centre la prévention
et le traitement qui sont normalement
des bases cardinal de la médecine et qui
sont complètement mises de côté depuis
de manière inquiétante d'ailleurs par
certains à partouche mais par certains
depuis quelques mois et en tout cas par
les gouvernements l alerte là c'est la
découverte de cette nouvelle sous jean
paul stahl il ya eu donc cost
présent en conseil de défense sanitaire
présidée par emmanuel macron qui lui
aussi est positif à roko vie de 19 ans
on le rappelle est donc cette décision
de suspendre tous les déplacements
depuis le royaume-uni pour un délai de
48 heures votre avis sur cette mesure et
ce délai est efficace ou pas jean paul
stahl alors j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis
particulier sur cette chaussette
décision là je voudrais juste revenir
sur l'efficacité du vaccin
l'efficacité du vaccin n'est pas
dépendante du type de ceux de mutation
qui est allégué par les par les
britanniques
donc effectivement le vaccin reste
efficace et restera efficace il faut pas
introduire le doute là dessus
compte tenu des mécanismes d'action et
des mécanismes immunitaires
effectivement y'a pas de il n'y a pas de
risque de baisse d'efficacité du vaccin
est le deuxième point les traitements je
suis absolument d'accord le mieux c'est
le traitement le tout c'est d'en avoir
et il n'y a aucun traitement
actuellement validé dans le monde qui
est montré la moindre licka site et sur
ceux sur ce coronavirus je parle de
démonstration scientifique
je ne parle pas d'allégations des uns et
des autres donc ce que vous dites j'en
passe assez qu'on est en mesure cette
senti site un qui parle on est en mesure
de dire concrètement aujourd'hui l'homme
cndh connais pas grand chose sur ce
virus mutant que le vaccin les vaccins
qui sont en cours de commercialisation
sont efficaces alors si vous en doutez
en tout cas c'est un vaccin qui est
comme je vous le disais multi souches
c'est la première chose et d'autres pas
qui ne vise pas les mécanismes de
transmission
donc on est on est vraiment dans une
banalité je veux dire de la continuité
de la démonstration qui a été fait sur
ces sur l'efficacité de ces vaccins et
leur sécurité d'ailleurs parce que je
crois qu'il faut quand même dire que les
deux vont ensemble
le 25 qui va être proposé
citoyen que je sois d'ailleurs sur l'une
files ère où que ce soit celui de
rebondir là les deux on démontré une
efficacité et une sécurité qui permet
d'être raisonnablement prescripteurs
sans aucune arrière-pensée sûr c'est sur
ces vaccins il s'appelle défiance aussi
au niveau de l'opinion publique
florian philippot déjà avoir l'avis du
vaccin initial et du virus initial c'est
une sorte de normal qu'ils aient des
doutes des inquiétudes de fans ya trois
mois je vous rappelle que beaucoup nous
expliquer que le rêve d y vivre c'était
formidable comme traitement et l'union
européenne faisait un chèque d'un
milliard d'euros à gillian le 8 octobre
pour en acheter
or si on écoutait certains comme raul tu
depuis le mois de mars et d'autres
disaient déjà que c'était inefficace des
conseillers et même parfois dangereux
donc il est normal que vu que ça vient
des mêmes on est quand même bien tout
simplement quelques doutes d'autant que
l'on n'en particulièrement de recul sur
ce vaccin fin ce soir l'hôpital de
chicago a stoppé la vaccination parce
qu'ils ont eu des problèmes chez les
soignants chercher quatre soignants dont
qu'ils ont comme ayant mis en pause ou
kg dire on est on est quand même dans un
deuil qu'il ya les précédents sur les
vaccins à la dengue la grippe a en suède
en 2009 etc
il faut quand même être extrêmement
prudent et on n'a pas les garanties de
cool ans ni même de transparence tout ça
se fait dans une grande opacité que ce
soit sur les contrats négociés par
l'union européenne on n'a pas le droit
d'en savoir reconnaître tout ça n'est
quand même pas là pour rassurer mais je
suis pas d'accord sur le traitement je
veux dire vous vous dites monsieur ce
talent qui a pas de traitement d'autres
professeurs de médecine disent qu'il ya
des traitements en france comme à
l'étranger et les utilisent
l'ivermectine hydroxy chloroquine
azithromycine les mêmes en prévention
alors nous avons appris par une médecin
ce soir de la pitié salpêtrière que des
recommandations seraient donnés en
prévention sur la vitamine t
ça fait six mois qu'il ya des médecins
qui le disent alors si ça vient en
recommandations officielles dans les
jours qui viennent c'est ce qu'elle dit
tant mieux mais enfin ça fait six mois
que il ya des médecins qui disent il
faut recommander de la vitamine d parce
que c'est efficace et on voit que ceux
qui sont en carence de vitamine d font
souvent des formes plus grave de kobe 19
donc si vous voulez moi je pense qu'on
va sacrifier le pays parce confinement
l'a déjà fait largement avec des effets
sanitaires collatéraux des effets
économiques sociaux psychiatrique
dévastateur je parle même pas de la
ruine de nos
liberté c'était un drame par ailleurs il
est inadmissible et à fergie tout de
suite si la casemate sainte
avec les incertitudes mais on oublie au
milieu peut-être sciemment quels
traitements la prévention et tout ça
aide-moi jeu et on va revenir sur la
stratégie d'ailleurs de lutte contre
l'épidémie au niveau européen mais il ya
plusieurs questions d'efficacité de des
vaccins face à ce virus mutant et puis
aussi la présence de ce nouveau virus
sur le territoire français ça c'est une
question aussi qui va se poser dans les
jours à venir puisque les présents au
royaume uni en italie en afrique du sud
est ce qu'on est capable de nous de le
repérer
s'il existe sur le territoire jean
pascal bien sûr on est tout à fait
capable de le centrale de référence pour
ce type de virus qui est parfaitement
outillé qu'il fait qu'il fait très très
bien donc de ceux de ce point de vue là
il n'y a pas de ya pas de vrais soucis
si jamais il ya le le repérer le
séquences et il y aura un séquençage
avec identification
donc de ce point de vue là du point de
vue purement technique il ya il n'y a
vraiment aucun souci
mais je le répète la question se pose
pas franchement là et qu'il soit un peu
plus ou un peu moins transmissibles à la
limite peu importe il va pas est
transmissible d'une façon différente
il va être transmis s'il peut être un
peu plus par le par le biais des aérien
mais il l'est déjà
donc si on on continue à impliquer et on
n'applique pas assez ce qui vous
expliquent qu'on a actuellement dix sept
mille cas nouveau par jour le cir on
continue à ne pas appliquer les mesures
de prévention mallet le virus peut être
un peu plus contagieux j'en sais encore
rien se transmettra il y aura une
troisième vague mais il n'y a pas
forcément besoin d'un virus plus
contagieux pour avoir la troisième vague
si on ne respecte pas encore une fois
les mesures barrières
cette contagion et les extrêmement
simple c'est un individu porteur du
virus qui par des sécrétions
respiratoires le transmet à l'individu
récepteur c'est
ces gens s'installent en a donné
en attendant jean paul stahl la france
elle a bien décidé quand même en conseil
de défense sanitaire dans la foulée dans
le sillage de plusieurs pays européens
qui ont supprimé les liaisons avec le
royaume-uni donc là de suspendre quand
même les déplacements en provenance du
royaume uni pendant un délai de 48
heures ma foi c'est une prius est une
décision politique aux scientifiques
mais c'est nécessaire je veux dire par
là que c'est effectivement une
précaution qui est qui et qui est sans
doute nécessaire en attendant d'y voir
un peu plus clair
mais très sincèrement ça à mon avis ça
change pas grand chose
et de toute façon si le virus est aussi
présent de façon aussi importante en
bretagne il n'est déjà dans votre pays
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il est
déjà en italie les en afrique du sud etc
et est très certainement ils n'ont pas
de circulaire à bas prix dans l'est dans
les pays européens
donc on a mon avis ça change pas grand
chose
florian philippot qu'encore une fois la
france elle va pas dans le même sens de
ses voisins européens qui ont carrément
supprimer les liaisons pour l'instant
avec le royaume uni
pour l'instant elle prend des décisions
sur 48 heures et puis aussi il ya un
couvre-feu ont reconfirme pas comme dans
nous nous chez nos voisins européens
enfin attention à ce qu'on appelle
confinement chez nos voisins européens
parce que c'est pas du tout la même
définition à la plupart du temps sauf en
espagne par exemple qu'en france qu'on
allait confinement film en français
quant aux à la gestion de nos frontières
nationales mais ça c'est une pathologie
macro viste et française c'est à dire
que nous on estime que leurs frontières
nationales doivent être décidées par
l'union européenne banque à chaque fois
on soit on prend pas de mesures je
rappelle qu'on les avait pas fermée lors
du premier confinement soit on en prend
pour 48 heures parce qu'on veut
absolument que ce soit l'union
européenne qui décide à faire les autres
pays n'ont pas ces pudeurs
il décide dans l'intérêt normalement de
leur peuple et idlib estime ce qui est
normal qu'ils sont souverains sur leurs
frontières nationales mais pas sur
akrour qui a vraiment une mentalité de
lacs et de bruxelles et madame merkel de
ce point de vue là
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on vous dit on
n'a pas les continents mais j'espère
qu'on fera plus de confinement enfin je
veux dire il faut arrêter cette folie de
toute façon il faut arrêter de croire
qu'on est comme des apprentis sorciers
qu'on peut maîtriser la dynamique
naturelle d'un virus il ya les pays
d'extrême orient qui s'en sont très bien
sortis japon corée du sud ils n'ont
jamais fermé ils ont jamais fait de
confinement et jour jamais fait tout ça
il avait simplement ils ont un très bon
système de santé dans lequel ils ont
investi massivement alors que nous on la
détruit depuis 20 ans par l'austérité
ils ont misé sur les antiviraux ils ont
fermé immédiatement leurs frontières
quand il fallait le faire moi que ses
loyers et et puis ils ont si vous voulez
des techniques modernes les uv pour par
exemple nettoyer les rames de métro tous
les soirs ils ont investi là-dedans dans
les purificateurs d'air dans les salles
de classe tout ce qu'on fait pas parce
que nous sommes en voie tiers
mondisation à cause de l'austérité
donc franchement moi je le souhaite
qu'on sort de cette folie et je crains
que le mutant renforce la folie et
l'hystérie merci beaucoup à vous florian
philippot président un des patriotes
merci également info jean paul stahl
professeur émérite de maladies
infectieuses au chu de grenoble